timsit merci d'être avec nous j'aime
patrick piana barak ont et l'aéronavale
quoi et maintenant on va traiter une
question spectacle
il a triomphé à la gaîté montparnasse et
maintenant ils auront points à la salle
pleyel je suis fou de patrick timsit
voilà je vous lire alors ce qu'il faut
préciser c'est que je pense spectacle
avec ce spectacle on se réfère
[Applaudissements]
mais le jour de l'achat du championnat
que là il passe le trois mâts sur ses
limites à vannes c'est sa mère
alala parce que la promotion du jour au
rond-point la salle pleyel
oui aux castrais ont fait la gaieté ça y
est c'est le spectacle qui a été capté
la salle pleyel à sa avoir fait un
triomphe à la gaîté honda et moi je fais
comme ça comme ça m'a dit bon voilà oui
mais moi je fais comme ça juste pas dire
[Applaudissements]
patrick au toit d'un doute on retrouve
bien en prime sur ces 8 samedi prochain
oui absolument ne le rendra
oui avec matin qu'un spectacle catherine
ont fait la gaîté montparnasse oui a
triomphé à la gaîté montparnasse après
avoir également aux pointes avait
triomphé aussi au oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'accord en fait en fait ils savaient
pas quoi faire comme du viol alors on
dit on va faire un truc je le déteste
merci les chéris des questions vous avez
des oeufs a b c ou d
sachez qu'il y à un oeuf dur à chaque
fois love dur correspond à l'offre de la
bonne réponse ok d'accord
les autres eux sont pas bons on crut pas
bon la rue donc cassé sur la tête donc
oeuvre qui casse la gueule of kick ass
off qui tâche
d'accord j'ai compris le jeu oui on joue
avec nos également chez vous lors du
salon de l'agriculture
emmanuel macron adopté agathe la poule
isabelle la colombe martin la vache ou
jean-michel le lapin faut aller à noah
n'y a pas de casse et ouais non non j'ai
hyper mal lamerat pas trop fort elle
avait mal juste une commotion cérébrale
on a un avis qui m'envoie une bonne très
drôle qui me dit à gâteau poules voilà
merci la poule pas mal j'aime bien oui
ça vole déjà gatopoulos ap l'agathois
gâteau poule k bientôt la nasa pas merci
il ya bernès qui est un coup de griffe
symbole c'est moi j'ai un coup de griffe
contre votre festin léché au printemps
déguisements déguisement mais 120 non ça
c'était vraiment j'attends des numéros
mois
on était dans les années 80 je me
faisais des javanais hélas hélas non
vraiment rien des liens et franchement
vous avez vu comme ça fait mal très mal
quels que soient les cas c'est ce qu'on
fait soi même tout à fait très mal
allez les chéris deuxième question
qu'ont déclaré les chevaliers du fiel ce
week end top chef et interminables dans
cette les stars n'a aucun intérêt
koh lanta est truqué ou the cover nous
manque l'émission qui avait près de
sursee lu à obala bat jean michel maire
voilà à fait limité sur le cac c'est là